so sometimes our current president
exposes that he doesn't know basic
political facts like what's the nuclear
triad or what did Ronald Reagan do with
taxes for example if some other random
bit of knowledge right sometimes though
he doesn't know the simplest things that
most sort of financially stable
Westerners would know such as there's a
thing called HPV the human papilloma
hrus papilloma virus and there's HIV
right the human immunodeficiency virus
which leads to AIDS in absolutely
stunning video that I'm gonna play for
you Bill Gates the founder of Microsoft
and ultra billionaire philanthropist
Bill Gates talks about how Donald Trump
on multiple occasions asked Bill Gates
if HPV and HIV were the same thing Chris
Hayes had the video and his MSNBC show
and here's just a short part of that
clip he wanted to know if there was a
difference between HIV and HPV so I was
able to explain that those are rarely
confused with each other bill gates
immediately smeared as a liar by the
Trump astride but what why would Bill
Gates lie about this right like why
would Bill Gates concoct a lie that
Trump doesn't know the difference
between HPV and HIV and really who are
you gonna trust right you clowns are you
gonna trust one of the world's most
successful humanitarian philanthropist
who has as a life mission to deal with
some of the worst diseases in the world
or are you gonna trust Trump who lies
about everything
obviously Bill Gates is lying right in
another part of this event Gates said
that Trump during his meeting with Gates
was referring to himself in the third
person which also sounds just about
right and totally unsurprising in every
way and everything that Bill Gates said
fits perfectly with what we know about
Trump first of all that he's really
confused about medical stuff that's the
pattern number two that he's really
confused about vaccines which comes up
as well also it doesn't seem Trump cares
about AIDS and that was evidenced by the
resignation of six members of that
hiv/aids committee who said Trump
doesn't care about AIDS so we're
quitting
I have no reason whatsoever to doubt
Bill Gates here and really Trump should
know about HIV and HPV because during
the 1980s
the AIDS and HIV crisis was perhaps
worse in New York City sure that's where
Trump lived and HPV is the most common
sexually transmitted disease which is
also some believed all these women who
said that they've had affairs with Trump
and unprotected sex yes
maybe he come across that at one point
yeah not because of anything about the
women specifically but just about the
prevalence of HPV right and gates also
said that during the meeting Trump
wanted to start an anti-vaxxer committee
of some kind and gates tried to talk him
out of it Bill Gates said in both of
those two meetings he asked me if
vaccines weren't a bad thing because he
was considering a commission to look
into the ill effects of vaccines Robert
Kennedy jr. was advising him that
vaccines were causing bad things and I
said no that's a dead end that would be
a bad thing don't do that this is the
theme when smart people meet with Trump
they're stunned by his ignorant sand
this is actually super interesting when
Trump shows up at a rally with a planned
speech and this hand-picked group of
sycophants he isn't as obviously just
dumb right and maybe in a room full of
his most feverish supporters he's not
actually that dumb in comparison I don't
really know I don't know enough Trump
supporters to know as soon as you put
Trump in a room with people like Bill
Gates and Elon Musk and others those
meetings are rarely televised but the
impression that we get from people in
the room is it is shocking how
unintelligent and ignorant Trump appears
to be which when you sit down with the
guy I would imagine becomes really
obvious you put Bill Gates in Elon Musk
in a room with Donald Trump and all of a
sudden you're like this this guy doesn't
know anything and it actually explains a
lot about how those guys and and women
as well but by those guys I mean
specifically gates and musk they've
bailed on opportunities to work with
Trump it all fits together yeah I mean I
guess if you're giving a speech in front
of your supporters whatever you say will
pass you don't need to say anything too
intelligent or less you're trying to
impress these people around you like
y'all Elon Musk and Bill Gates so you
have to up the ante a little bit I think
yeah or even just not say blisteringly
stupid things that make you push away
that force the the people you're trying
to get to help you with stuff to say I
just can't work with this guy not at all
shocking if you think we should distrust
Bill Gates about this
why I'm open to having my mind changed
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by the master
crypto currency trader an online course
created by crypto 80 this is a fantastic
new class for anyone who's new to the
world of crypto currency and Bitcoin and
maybe you've heard about crypto
currencies you don't know much about it
you don't have any idea how to get
started this is the perfect way to do it
and the course was designed by veteran
crypto investor Chris Kony who has more
than 10 years experience in currency
trading and he starts out teaching you
all the sort of core concepts in a way
that's really easy to absorb he lays out
a simple step-by-step system for making
smart decisions as a trader and by the
time you're done with the course you'll
have all the tools and knowledge you'll
need to get started in the world of
trading crypto currencies of course the
usual legal disclaimer I have to tell
you I'm not giving you financial advice
but I am telling you that the course is
definitely worth checking out you can
get 25% off by going to crypto versity
dot-com / Pakman and when you sign up
using that link you'll get 250 bucks
worth of Bitcoin but only if you go to
crypto versity comm / Pakman and the
first 50 people who sign up will get
this special deal that's CR y PT o ve RS
ity comm / PA k ma n if you're watching
this on youtube I've put a link
underneath the video